trouver une porte de sortie diplomatique
voilà l'objectif de la rencontre entre
anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov à
genève les deux délégations doivent
désamorcer une situation explosive
la russie ainsi massées plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de soldats à la
frontière avec l'ukraine si moscou
réfute toute volonté d' invasion elle
exige que l'otan refuse formellement
d'intégrer kiev dans son alliance
faisant craindre une escalade
irréversible
un air de guerre froide flotte donc
entre les deux puissances atmosphère
renforcé par l'arrivée de troupes russes
ces derniers jours en biélorussie et des
opérations navales d'ampleur annoncé par
le kremlin les etats-unis et leurs
alliés occidentaux ont de leur côté
affiché leur unité une impasse pour de
nombreux observateurs
highfield son
mari
d'avoir
pendant ce temps washington a annoncé
200 millions de dollars dettes
sécuritaire défensif supplémentaire à
l'ukraine les états unis autorise aussi
les pays baltes à expédier des armes de
fabrication américaine à kiev